.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
# Als Bueb hani mir dänkt,
es müess doch schön sii,
# uf irgendeme Meerschiff
Kapitän z sii.
Christian Jott Jenny
ist Entertainer, Tenor und
Gründer des Jazzfestivals St. Moritz.
Und seit eineinhalb Jahren
ist er nun auch Gemeindepräsident
des Nobelortes im Engadin.
Damit sorgt er für viel Unruhe
und bringt die gewohnten politischen
Prozesse gehörig durcheinander.
Wissen Sie, wenn gewisse
alteingesessene Lokalpolitiker
immer noch nicht damit leben können,
dass jemand gewählt wird,
der bisher unpolitisch war
und in keiner Partei ist,
und somit halt das eigene Weltbild,
das vielleicht
ein bisschen antiquiert ist,
so durcheinanderbringt,
ist das definitiv ein Problem
der anderen, nicht meins.
Liebe Stimmbürgerinnen
und Stimmbürger,
wie ich an der letzten
Gemeindeversammlung ...
Verdammt,
das ist das falsche Blatt.
St. Moritz könne es besser,
versprach Jenny im Wahlkampf.
Kann er sein Versprechen einlösen?
"Motion CVP,
Lohnkürzung Gemeindepräsident ..."
* Lachen im Publikum *
* Klingelton *
Aha, jetzt wird's spannend.
Es ist da.
Ich hab's aber noch nicht angesehen.
Gut.
Ich zünde mir erst eine Ziga...
Machen wir's dramaturgisch richtig.
"Lieber Christian" ...
Ich zünde erst an.
* Leise klassische Musik *
Die Musik ist gut.
"Lieber Christian, lieber Sigi,
hier die Resultate
des zweiten Wahlgangs."
"Christian: 894, Sigi: 822."
"Ich gratuliere Christian
herzlich zur Wahl."
* Jauchzen *
Was geht Ihnen durch den Kopf?
Ja ... Was man jetzt so tun muss.
Ja, mal abklären ...
... was man als Gemeindepräsident
zu tun hat?- Genau.
Aber ich habe viele nette Leute,
die mir das erklären werden.
Dezember 2019,
ein knappes Jahr nach seiner Wahl.
Christian Jott Jenny
vor einer ersten Bewährungsprobe.
Ich muss Ihnen einen Gruss
von meiner Schulfreundin ausrichten.
Wer ist das?
- Gisela Lacher.
Ach je! Richten Sie ihr auch
einen lieben Gruss aus.
Der Entertainer leitet
seine erste Gemeindeversammlung.
Guten Abend. Willkommen.
Tschau. Hallo.
* Klingeln einer Glocke *
Liebe St. Moritzerinnen,
liebe St. Moritzer,
ich will Sie im Namen des Gemeinde-
vorstandes und des Gemeinderates
herzlich zur heutigen
Gemeindeversammlung begrüssen.
Glauben Sie mir: Ich bin genauso
nervös wie vor einer Premiere -
vielleicht noch nervöser.
Ich deute das aber
als gutes Zeichen.
Ohne eine gewisse
Premierenanspannung
gibt's keine Höchstleistungen.
Aber bitte verzeihen Sie mir:
Ich übe diese Rolle
heute zum ersten Mal aus
und versuche, den Abend so schlank
und rund wie möglich zu gestalten.
Herr Häberli, bitte.
Ich bitte auch Sie,
sich kurz zu fassen.- Ja, ja.
Sehr geehrter Herr Gemeindepräsident
und offensichtlich überforderte,
wenn nicht gar korrupte
Behördenmitglieder,
das EW betrügt seine Kunden,
was unsere Vorstände und Räte
offensichtlich völlig normal finden.
Mit Verdacht, dass sie eben Mafiosi
sind, zumindest aber Arschkriecher.
Gut, Punkt. Wir nehmen es
ins heutige Protokoll auf.
* Applaus *
Ich möchte hier noch kurz
eine kleine Antwort geben.
Die GPK, also der Präsident der GPK
und meine Wenigkeit
waren vor zwei Wochen
bei Ihnen zu Hause
und klärten all diese Sachen
im Detail.
Es ist also nicht so,
dass wir da untätig wären.
Ja, das gebe ich zu.
- Gut.
Danke vielmals wenigstens dafür.
Er hat die Gemeindeversammlung heute
super gemanagt.
Das ist eine gute Sache.
Und sonst denke ich ...
Was soll ich sagen? Ich war sehr
skeptisch, als er gewählt wurde.
Ich denke,
ich revidiere meine Meinung.
Er macht seine Sache gut.
Ich denke, er bringt
viel frischen Wind nach St. Moritz.
Er hatte zu Beginn
sehr viele Skeptiker.
Ich glaube, er macht sich sehr gut.
Er hat durch
seine aufgeschlossene Art
das Weltoffene
wieder etwas mehr unterstrichen.
Das ist uns sehr wichtig.
Jennys Alltag
findet nun im Gemeindehaus statt.
Hier geht's um Aktenstudium,
politische Knochenarbeit, Sitzungen
und das Führen der Verwaltung
mit 300 Mitarbeitern.
Besprechung
mit dem Chef des Steueramts.
Wie wird denn die Stufe eingeteilt?
Mit Jahren?
Also, das hier
ist die Einteilung der Klassen.
Das ist klar.
- Das sind die normalen Klassen.
Und jede Klasse
hat bis zu 20 Stufen.
Dann bist du auf dem Maximum.
Bald nach Amtsantritt
wurde der Vorwurf laut,
die politische Knochenarbeit
sei nicht Jennys Sache.
Details interessierten ihn nicht,
es fehle ihm in vielen Dossiers
das Know-how.
Das ist eine Floskel, die ich so
nicht auf mir sitzen lasse.
Wann ist man dossiersicher?
Wenn man das Dossier gut kennt.
- Ja, gut.
Ich kenne nicht jedes Detail.
Das ist aber
auch nicht meine Aufgabe.
Ich bestimme meine Agenda,
ich mache kein Micromanagement.
Das habe ich immer gesagt.
Das interessiert mich nicht.
Dafür hat man ja
z.B. einen Rechnungschef,
der bis auf den letzten Fünfer genau
weiss, was wo ist - meistens.
Mitten in St. Moritz steht
ein bekanntes baufälliges Haus.
Es gehört Adolf Häberli, der in der
Gemeindeversammlung protestiert hat.
Häberli behauptet, der Boden unter
seinem Haus sei um 30 cm abgesunken,
seit die Gemeinde
gegenüber ein Parkhaus gebaut habe.
Seither hat sich der 86-Jährige
in einen kafkaesken Rechtsstreit
hineingesteigert.
Solche Fälle
will der neue Gemeindepräsident
nicht vom Bürostuhl aus lösen,
sondern im direkten Gespräch.
Guten Morgen.
Hier sind die Zeitungen.
Morgen. Merci.
- Guten Nachmittag, bald mal.
So, erzähl mal: Wie geht's?
Ich habe noch nie eine Antwort
auf einen Brief bekommen.
Die Antwort ...
Das waren letztes Jahr im Schnitt
zwei bis drei Briefe pro Woche.
Ja, ja.- Herr Häberli,
Sie sind doch einfach stur.
Nein.
Wenn Sie für die Einhaltung der
Gesetze und Verfassung einstehen,
sind Sie dann stur
oder sind Sie ein Urdemokrat?
Aber Dölf, der Fall
ist bald 40 oder 50 Jahre alt.
Drei... 63 Jahre.
- Oh, Entschuldigung.
Ich habe untertrieben.
- Und der ist von 68.
Ich habe gewisse Sympathien
für solche Menschen
und möchte auch Herrn Häberli
das Problem lassen, das er hat.
Ich bin auch tief davon überzeugt,
wenn wir das Problem lösen würden,
würden wir
ein grosses neues Problem schaffen.
Ich glaube auch, dass Herr Häberli
an diesem Problem lebt und wächst.
Es hat eine
fast dürrenmatsche Komponente.
Willst du was zu Mittag?
Ich habe ein Sandwich zu viel.
Im Streitfall
kommt Jenny auch nicht weiter,
aber den Draht zu seinen Bürgern
hat er.
Die alte Reithalle in St. Moritz
ist einsturzgefährdet.
Es fehlt das Geld
für eine Renovierung.
Seit Jahren steht sie leer,
doch das ist passé:
... in diesem hochgradig
einsturzgefährdeten Gebäude.
Das ist eine Sensation.
Ich weiss nicht, ob Sie ...
Der Gemeindepräsident organisiert
die erste Veranstaltung gleich selbst
und vermarktet sie
in einem eigenen Video.
So, welcome,
welcome to the Presidential Report,
so nennen wir das jetzt,
vom 1. August 2019,
dem 728. Geburtstag
von Mutter Helvetia,
an einem wunderbaren,
traditionellen Ort,
der über 100-jährigen Reithalle
von St. Moritz,
die wir extra für den heutigen
Feiertag geöffnet haben.
# Olé, olé, olé, olé-hiiiii...
Damit löst er mit viel Brimborium
ein erstes Wahlversprechen ein,
obwohl es immer hiess,
das gehe nicht.
# ... von Caritas.
Ich muss ... Also ich, der Vorstand,
muss die politische Verantwortung
übernehmen, das ist ganz klar.
Wenn es dort eine Katastrophe gibt,
sind wir schuld.
Aber es gibt immer
verschiedene Perspektiven.
Man kann ja auch sagen:
"Es geht vielleicht
nur zwei oder drei Wochen,
vielleicht geht es nicht
ein ganzes Jahr."
Aber man findet immer Lücken,
auch bei einem Nein.
Ich sage immer: Ein Nein ist in der
Verwaltung immer die sichere Seite.
Da macht man nichts falsch.
Ich habe aber gemerkt, dass es
auch in diesem Haus viele gibt,
die durchaus in der Lage sind,
mal Ja zu sagen: "Ja, aber ..."
Aber wenn man sagt:
"Ich übernehme die Verantwortung."
"Ich würde das gerne so machen.
Finden wir einen Weg?"
Dann ist durchaus auch der Wille da,
etwas zu verändern
und etwas zu tun,
was den Leuten entgegenkommt.
Fahne.
* Lachen im Publikum *
Danke.- Wenn das heute
nicht extravagant war,
fresse ich einen Besen.
Das war einfach
ein umwerfender 1. August
und mehr als extravagant.
Ich bin 74, in St. Moritz
geboren und aufgewachsen,
aber so einen 1. August
habe ich noch nie erlebt.
Ein glücklicher Zufall will es,
dass in Jennys erstem Amtsjahr
eine 100 Mio. schwere indische
Hochzeit für Aufregung sorgt.
Der reichste Inder, Mukesh Ambani,
veranstaltet ein pre-wedding
für seinen Sohn.
Der Gigantismus
spaltet die Bevölkerung.
Einerseits ist St. Moritz
weltweit in den Schlagzeilen,
andererseits laufen Anwohner Sturm
gegen das Spektakel,
denn sie haben nichts
vom rein privaten Fest
ausser der Halle und Chilbi
direkt vor ihren Wohnungen.
In persönlichen Gesprächen
kann Jenny die Situation entschärfen.
Ich habe es übernommen.
Ich bin jetzt
knapp sechs Wochen im Amt.
Da ist sicher einiges
nicht optimal gelaufen.
Da muss man auch
mit den Menschen dort drüben reden.
Ich habe sie jetzt kennengelernt
und ihnen versprochen,
dass wir gemeinsam
ein Debriefing machen
und künftig
früher miteinander reden.
Der Gemeindepräsident
will mit einer Schar Schulkinder
mit Glocken und Peitschen, dem sog.
Chalanda-Marz-Umzug, zum Brautpaar.
(Frau) Everyone! Everyone! Pst!
St. Moritz
soll ein Ort für Superreiche sein,
aber nicht abgeschirmt
vom Alltag der Einwohner.
Do you have an announcement?
Es gilt,
Überzeugungsarbeit zu leisten.
... and you can show them ...
... where they have to go.
- I'll show you the children.
Das ist das Beste, was man tun kann:
Kultur schenken und Kulturen ...
Die eine Kultur trifft die andere.
Besser kann es gar nicht sein.
(Lied über Lautsprecher)
# Congratulations ...
Schliesslich gelingt es Jenny,
ins Innere des Festzelts zu gelangen
und dem Brautpaar
die offiziellen Wünsche
von St. Moritz zu überbringen.
# ... thought you were above me.
# That I was only fooling myself
to think you loved me.
# But since tonight you said
you couldn't live without me ...
Zu guter Letzt verhandelt Jenny,
dass die Chilbi für die ganze St.
Moritzer Bevölkerung geöffnet wird.
Wir haben die Idee gleich, als sie
aus dem Flugzeug gestiegen sind,
der Brautmutter vorgeschlagen,
und sie fand das grossartig.
Wie ich herausgefunden habe,
bestimmt da die Brautmutter,
nicht der Alte.
Wenn der Gemeindepräsident
im Engadin und auch andernorts
mit seiner Show auf Tournee ist, baut
er solche Erfahrungen schamlos ein.
(Mit indischem Akzent)
"Dear Lord Major Jenny ..."
* Lachen *
Eine SMS. Eine SMS vom Brautvater.
"Dear Lord Major Jenny,
may I contact you?"
"I would like to invite you for tea,
a cup of tea."
Ich sage immer: Früher war ich
am Albanifest in Winterthur,
heute bin ich
am Ambanifest in St. Moritz.
Und ich habe jegliche ...
Eben, man hat im Voraus ...
Man darf nichts annehmen.
Das ist ganz klar.
Es ist alles sehr seriös abgelaufen.
Im Nachhinein gehe ich durchaus
im Oktober dort in die Ferien.
* Lachen *
(Mit indischem Akzent)
We'll make you a very nice holiday
if you want to come to India.
Im alten, umgebauten Olympiastadion
von St. Moritz
wohnt Jenny, der Zürcher,
wenn er im Engadin ist -
nach eigenen Angaben zu etwas mehr
als zwei Dritteln seiner Zeit.
Das Gemeindepräsidium wird
mit rund 250'000 Fr. üppig bezahlt.
Im Wahlkampf sagte Jenny, das sei
aber kein Grund für seine Kandidatur.
Ich finde, er verdient viel zu viel.
Eine völlige Unsumme.
Das ist übrigens
der best verdienende
Gemeindepräsident der Schweiz.
Dann müssen Sie beantragen,
dass Ihr Lohn gekürzt wird.
Das kann man machen.
Wenn man nett ist, kann man auch
einen Teil an Institutionen spenden.
Prompt kürzten die Kollegen
im Gemeindevorstand
dem neuen Mitglied
den Lohn um 50'000 Fr.
# ... und ganz früsch gwählt -
es isch en Hohn -
# chürzeds mir zallererscht de Lohn.
# Han erscht
im zweite Wahlgang gwunne,
# aber mir mag halt niemert
öppis gunne.
Im Gegenzug verhandelte Jenny, dass
sein Pensum auf 90 % reduziert wird.
So kann er seine künstlerischen
Aktivitäten rechtfertigen.
Also kein voller Einsatz
für St. Moritz?
Das mit den Pensen
ist sowieso ein Witz.
Entweder man ist Gemeindepräsident
oder nicht.
Wenn man Gemeindepräsident ist,
ist man das auch,
wenn man nachts aufs WC geht.
Ich halte nicht viel
von diesen Pensen.
Die Frage bleibt: Ist Jenny
der Richtige für das Amt?
Zweifel äusserten auch enge Freunde
schon vor dem Amtsantritt.
Die Politik wird ihn sehr zermürben.
Ich glaube, da geht es uns gleich.
Obwohl er an und für sich
ein Beamter ist.
Eben.
- Ja.
In der Politik
ist es einfach sehr oft so,
dass man sehr viele Kompromisse
eingehen muss,
dass man kein richtig gutes,
pures Produkt rauskriegt.
Man muss ganz speziell gebaut sein,
um das machen zu können.
Und dazu bereit sein,
die ganzen Kontroversen auf sich zu
nehmen und Abschnitte zu machen.
Ich glaube,
das würde ihm nicht liegen.
Ich habe dir eine Einladung
für ein Zoom-Meeting geschickt.
Der Gemeindepräsident schaltet seinen
Freund wegen Corona aus Rom zu.
Das ist ja grossartig. Hervorragend.
Sachs ist der Besitzer des Olympia-
stadions und Jennys WG-Partner.
Haben Sie sich geirrt?
Also, an den Satz kann ich mich
natürlich sehr genau erinnern.
Natürlich habe ich mich geirrt.
Irgendwo bin ich
über meinen Irrtum sehr froh.
Christian hat das jetzt so gut ...
Er ist das angegangen,
ohne einen Kompromiss
mit seinem Charakter
und seiner Art zu schliessen.
Auch die Skeptiker von damals sehen,
dass es nicht immer so laufen muss.
Es kann auch etwas flüssiger,
etwas offener, etwas freier laufen.
In dieser Art und Weise
erfüllt Christian Jott Jenny
sein Präsidium in der Tat.
"Liebe Gäste,
liebe St. Moritzerinnen,
liebe St. Moritzer,
liebe St. Moritzenden."
Hm, das ist falsch. Gut.
"Liebe Einheimische, liebe alle."
Dann kommt die Fahne.
Ich sage: "Fahne."
Dann sage ich: "Fahne".
Können wir das üben? Fahne.
Das ist nicht lustig.
Fahne, ernst. Ja.
"Verstehen Sie mich nicht falsch:
Der Blick zurück
hat auch hier in St. Moritz
immer wieder
seine Existenzberechtigung."
"Und das einzigartige Bobbahn..."
Fahne. Genau, üben.
Erstens sind die
überhaupt nicht frech,
sondern ich lasse die
protokollarische Tradition aufleben.
Die hat noch nie
so gelebt wie jetzt.
Der Weibel wird wieder
als Weibel eingesetzt,
die Flagge flattert wieder im Wind,
sie wird wieder genutzt.
Man nutzt den Weibel,
weil man ihn hat.
Das ist auch schön.
Ich habe immer gesagt:
Ich mag diese ...
Diese amtlichen Traditionen
finde ich toll.
Darum muss man sie nutzen.
Wenn man das mit einem Zwinkern
in den Augen macht,
ist das auch gut, sonst
wird es etwas sehr nationalistisch,
und das muss ja auch nicht sein.
Gleich kommt die Fahne. "Was es
bedeutet und was dahintersteckt."
Fahne.
Der eine Presidential Report,
der fürs neue Jahr,
hat zwar noch eine Strafanzeige bei
der Staatsanwaltschaft Graubünden
nach sich gezogen,
wegen Fahrens mit Fahne.
Das ist
eine sehr interessante Anklage,
aber die Staatsanwaltschaft
muss selbst wissen, was sie tut.
Doch nicht alle finden das lustig.
Aus dem Gemeindevorstand gelangte
eine interne Mail an die Presse.
Darin machen die Kollegen aus der
Exekutive Jenny schwere Vorwürfe.
Sie verlangen von ihm mehr Präsenz,
eine straffere Führung
und bessere Dossierkenntnisse.
Sonst müsse man vielleicht
seine Aufgaben neu verteilen.
* Feierliche Musik *
Mario Salis war früh skeptisch
gegenüber Jennys Kandidatur.
Und doch konnte Jenny
ihn dazu bringen,
an einer seiner Premieren
eine Einlage zum Besten zu geben.
Nehmt ihr noch einen Drink?
Ich kenne ihn jetzt näher,
auch als Mensch.
Ja.
- Ich habe ihn positiv erlebt.
Jetzt muss er sich
in den vier Jahren beweisen.
Ich bin überzeugt, mit meiner
Unterstützung macht er das.
So ist es eben.
- Ja.
Sehr interessant. Man muss
seine Meinung auch ändern können.
Doch in der Sache bleibt Salis hart.
Fahne.
Das ist Christian Jenny.
Das kann er. Das macht er.
Er kann motivieren,
er kann die Leute reinziehen.
Aber das mit seiner Fahne ...
Also ... Aber ...
Für mich wäre es wichtiger, wenn er
politisch mehr bringen würde.
Die Kritik ist natürlich klar da:
Sie sind zu selten auf dem Amt.
Sie sind nicht ansprechbar.
Offenbar werden Ihre Aufgabenbereiche
nicht pflichtbewusst genug erfüllt.
Das ist zumindest, was Ihre Kollegen
in dieser Mail diskutiert haben.
Ich bin 24 Std. ansprechbar, ich bin
besser erreichbar als alle anderen.
Man muss sich einfach
ein wenig daran gewöhnen,
dass das so ist, wie ich es mache.
Das ist mein Präsidium.
Ich übe es so aus und gestalte es
so, wie es für mich funktioniert.
# Mir mag halt niemert öppis gunne.
# Niemert öppis gunne.
# Es isch halt eifach gspunne.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Daniel McMinn - 2020